[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 18 octobre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
les titres de cette édition une volonté
faire pression sur le gouvernement cinq
présidents de départements franciliens
tenait une réunion publique hier à
versailles en présence du président du
sénat gérard larcher
ils veulent une métropole du grand paris
élargi aux frontières de l'île de france
nous les avons interrogés sur place du
en cours vient de lancer sa fête du goût
tout au long de l'année les écoliers de
la ville participeront à des animations
autour de l'alimentation ateliers
culinaires visites et spectacles
aujourd'hui par exemple il a été reçu
par le lycée de l'hôtellerie de
guyancourt pour un repas enfin invité de
ce journal noémie de saint sernin libye
noise hauteur et coach en développement
personnel publie chez eyrolles ai les
clés du passé est libre ses solutions
pour connaître le bonheur en se libérant
du poids de son passé
ils étaient réunis hier à versailles
cinq présidents de départements
franciliens donnait une réunion publique
au palais des congrès en présence de
gérard larcher président du sénat les
yvelines l'essonne la seine-et-marne le
val d'oise et les hauts-de-seine
souhaite une métropole du grand paris
régionale créée en 2016 elle regroupe
pour le moment la capitale et la petite
couronne exclusivement sans le reste de
l'ile-de-france et d'ici un mois le
gouvernement pourrait faire des annonces
sur la métropole un périmètre identique
avec une disparition des départements du
92 du 93 et du 94 cents à intégrer la
grande couronne francilienne
il ya ce sujet nous avons pu interroger
sur place hier le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines ainsi que
celui des oeufs des yvelines de pierre
bédier pardon ainsi que celui à des
hauts-de-seine patrick devedjian il on a
répondu aux questions de mélanie poker
de nicolas kirillovitch deuxième
opération d'envergure organisée par les
départements franciliens quelques jours
seulement après la conférence de presse
organisée à paris le 10 octobre
plusieurs départements français les élus
locaux se sont unies ici au palais des
congrès à versailles
objectif évidemment donner une nouvelle
fois votre avis sur l'avenir de la
métropole du grand paris car bédié
patrick devidjian merci de répondre à
nos questions première peut-être
question il ya dix jours vous étiez 7
aujourd'hui vous êtes moins nombreux
pourquoi pierre bédier
on n'est pas moins nombreux il y avait
800 personnes dans la salle et nous
manquions que cette lajarrige évoqué les
présidents des partis bien entendu à
cette occasion ce sont les présidents de
conseil départemental de droite et du
centre qui se sont réunis et en juin
dans une ils étaient tous là dans une
réunion qui devait être à l'origine une
réunion pédagogique de nos deux
départements 78 92 pour parler de notre
projet de fusion est naturellement
stéphane troussel et favier de christian
favier par dangereux a oublié son prénom
pouvait pas aller jusqu'à participer à
une réunion publique de cette nature
mais sur le fond nous sommes d'accord
comme ils vont en vie la semaine
dernière donc sur le fond sans comprend
bien le message qui était portée
nouvelle fois ce soir c'est de vous
souhaiter une métropole du grand paris
de la région ile de france sont d'accord
pour rejeter
et qui établit par la loi aujourd'hui
donc une métropole élargi aux périmètres
delà de la région ile-de-france mais du
coup quel quel avenir pour cette pour
cette région ile de france il y a deux
entités deux collectivités de la même
taille
est-ce que ça fera pas un échelon de
trop et si oui lequel faudra supprimer
je pense qu'il faut raisonner en bloc
plutôt que de vouloir supprimer
vous avez le bloc communal qui est le
bloc répond aux préoccupations
quotidiennes des habitants
il est essentiel les élus les habitants
la scène leur mère ils aiment leur
commune ils en ont besoin et avec le
partenaire indispensable quelle
intercommunalité pour ces communes et
puis vous avez ce que nous ont créé que
le bloc métropolitaine qui est à
l'échelle de la région et qui englobe
donc les tous les départements est
l'émanation de tous ces départements
avec la métropole ça donne le bloc
contre pétain et là on importe des
services de proximité mais aussi des
services un peu plus stratégique
on met plus de moyens humains et
financiers donc on répond pas à cette
problématique connue de la région
ile-de-france ont tout est de la
métropole parisienne du millefeuille
territorial sa phrase mille feuille
territorial c'est une blague
le millefeuille territorial c'est l'état
qu il a créée en 1999 ils ont créé
l'intercommunalité en 2000 cas ils ont
créé la métropole
il y avait trois étages ils en ont fait
5 e
en même temps ils ont créé mille deux
cent soixante dix agences d'état c'est à
dire que c'est pas milf est un chou à la
crème
vous avez qu'est ce qu'on vous dit
concrètement est-ce que vous avez des
contacts directement avec le
gouvernement le président de la
république vous vous êtes opposés au
projet actuel les rumeurs vous le disiez
vous même dans la presse font état quand
même d'une métropole qui se fixerait à
la petite couronne plus certains
territoires de la couronne est ce que
vous me verrez vous de la presse est ce
que est ce qu est ce que qu'est-ce que
du coup vous êtes encore optimiste
est-ce que vous avez des informations
positives sur vos sur vos requêtes à
vous
peu importe que les informations soient
bonnes ou mauvaises
nous sommes optimistes par nature et on
se bat pas ce que c'est pour nous une
telle évidence qu'on ne peut pas séparer
la grande couronne de la petite couronne
pourquoi ne pas aussi installé comme on
le faisait entre l'allemagne de l'est et
l'allemagne de l'ouest des checkpoints
donc pour passer à vélizy mais ça c'est
là pour passer dans les hauts-de-seine
honorait checkpoint
il faudrait présenter un papier
d'identité en fait tout ça tout ça est
grotesque à une époque on nous parle de
mondialisation où on nous parle de
d'élargir nos horizons
en france on veut réduire le réseau et
construire des murs là où de toute
évidence il faut essayer d'être beaucoup
plus large beaucoup plus rassembleur
beaucoup plus dynamique et surtout
préoccupés par le développement
économique ce qu'on explique avec
patrick depuis le début notre projet de
fusion de départements
il est d'abord centrée sur cette idée
qu'il faut produire de la richesse pour
pouvoir la partager et que c'est la
condition sinequanone on finira j'espère
par faire entendre ce bon sens si je
prends de l'entente pas la france
pendant encore quelques années et
l'ile-de-france y perdra beau et si ce
message n'est pas entendue du coup quel
quel avenir pour la fusion 78,92 ça sera
du coup un projet a oubliées
concrètement c'est impossible de le
réaliser une énorme pierre bédier moi
nous sommes des gens tenaces et rassurez
vous
le combat continue la vie politique
c'est ça parfois on met très longtemps
pour faire aboutir
quelque chose d'important et
d'intelligence mais put allemand
l'intelligence c'est un peu comme un
bouchon de liège quand vous le tenez
avec une main de fer au fond de l'eau
bas ils remontent pas mais le jour où la
main s'en trouve hop le bouchon remonte
donc ça arrive moi une dernière question
pour le département des yvelines
supposons que la métropole reste dans le
schéma actuel est ce que vous êtes
inquiet pour l'avenir du département
concrètement à court terme n'ont rien ne
changera sauf si naturellement l'état
continue à nous saigner parce que les
collectivités locales sont encore appelé
à des efforts substantiels que l'état ne
s'appliquent pas lui-même mais c'est un
autre débat mais je suis inquiet à moyen
et surtout à long terme la volonté de
l'état de concentrer le département une
partie du territoire en ignorant d'une
autre partie du territoire elle et
pardonnez-moi si le mot enchante que
certains parce qu'il paraît très
excessif mais les criminels parce que
bien entendu il y aura moins de richesse
aujourd'hui d hiddink est ce que c'est
une zone urbaine dynamique qui partage
sa richesse par le biais du département
avec une zone rurale dont l'économie est
moins dynamique et c'est normal puisque
on ne demande pas la zone rurale d'être
en production de richesses on lui
demande d'être notre notre facteur
qualité de vie que tout le monde nous
envie c'est cet équilibre qui fait la
force des idées et cet équilibre est
gravement menacée par cette métropole
réduite aux acquêts
merci messieurs pour vos réponses
complet sur ce sujet le président du
groupe les républicains et indépendants
au conseil régional d'ile-de-france
othman natrue appellent aujourd'hui à
une fusion de la région est de la
métropole du grand paris elle yvelinois
demande au gouvernement de tenir compte
de la réalité du terrain
une fusion permettrait de supprimer un
échelon administratif trop nombreux en
france selon l'élu
son nom sera connu demain
saint quentin en yvelines à doit choisir
son nouveau président et les élus de
l'agglomération se réunissent demain en
conseil communautaire exceptionnel après
la démission de michel laugier élu
sénateur le mois dernier bon soir
joséphine coleman ce verger qui est avec
nous par téléphone vous êtes à la mère
de plaisir et vous assurer la présidence
par intérim de saint quentin en yvelines
jusqu'à demain donc vous allez être en
charge de la bonne tenue de ce scrutin
demain soir comment va se dérouler cette
séance spéciale qu'est ce qui est
finalement à l'ordre du jour demain l'a
écoutée spécial suis pas tout à fait
manquer une science tout à fait normal
dans l'installation d'un nouveau
président donc les choses se passent de
façon tout à fait logique
c'est à dire avec le doyen qui plan en
main la séance
et puisque ça se passe toujours comme ça
c'est à dire que c'est pas le président
par intérim qui fait la cérémonie on va
dire appelons ça comme ça que je vais
très important et donc en l'occurrence
c'est le maire de trappes un monsieur
valentin qui va effectivement étant le
doyen d'âge et d'ims présidé ce conseil
communautaire d'installation donc il va
y avoir une élection on va commencer par
une élection du président et ensuite
élections les vice-présidents et ensuite
alors on connaît pour le moment le
candidat de votre majorité la majorité
de droite c'est jean michel fourgous qui
est maire d'elancourt et qui a été
désigné à l'issue d'une primaire
organisée en interne est ce que d'autres
candidats se sont fait connaître où il
le peut ils pourront le faire demain en
début de séance elle a expliqué je ne
reviens pas être au courant des choses
je ne sais pas non pour le moment
personne ne s'est révélé comme étant
encore du tas pour pour demain voire
donc mais en même temps tout est
possible je ne peux pas vous dire je ne
suis pas dans le secret de tout le monde
il aura un seul candidat à droite vous
nous confirmez écoutez il y en a
certainement alors le scrutin de demain
comment a t'il se dérouler ça va être un
vote à bulletin secret ce sens oui bien
sûr jacques à bulletin secret c'est
toujours souhaité et puis il y aura
certainement aussi la présence d'annie
au noir ce qui a été demandé par le
président qui va effectivement tenir ce
conseil communautaire d'installation
donc ça va être ça va être mis en place
pour en tout cas là je dirais l'élection
du président dernière question joséphine
coleman ce berger qui est peut-être un
peu naïve cette question imaginons
demain un autre nom que celui de jean
michel fourgous sorte des urnes
peut-être même le vôtre quelle serait
votre réaction
vous avez une boule de cristal
ah non je vous pose la question écoutez
on pas en valeur s'en tenir à ce que je
vais lui c'est à dire que demain tout
une séance d'installation été prise
après vous savez la politique est
toujours très surprenante peut se passer
des choses on n'est pas on n'est pas
l'abri de quelques surprises
c'est bien ce que vous nous avons tout
de même eu lieu je n'en sais rien je ne
sais pas moi j'espère que les choses en
tout cas se passe dans une grande
sérénité avec calme et en tout cas avec
respect et que les choses qui doivent
être dupe il y en a très vite et que les
choses se passe du mieux possible c'est
tout ce que je peux souhaiter puisque
depuis le début et vous le savez je
défend avec force
l'intérêt général de notre agglomération
et de notre territoire
merci joséphine coleman ce berger
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle maire
de plaisir vous êtes présidente par
intérim de saint quentin en yvelines
jusqu'à demain soir puisque demain soir
en se tiennent les aller aux élections
le scrutin dont pour élire le nouveau
président ça sera en séance du conseil
communautaire il déménage quelques
mètres plus loin l'ifac yvelines vient
d'inaugurer ses nouveaux quartiers
avenue rené duguay trouin à voisins le
bretonneux l'institut de formation et
d'animation de
deux conseils présents depuis 1978 dans
le département avait besoin de locaux
plus adaptés bâtiments dont il est
désormais propriétaire écouté le
directeur au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude
on s'est rendu compte que c'était aussi
un moyen relativement économique puisque
nous avions un coup quasiment égale à
une location et un emplacement
centralisé au niveau du département des
yvelines est également des locaux qui
répondait davantage à nos besoins et en
l'occurrence en termes de développement
sur les formations que nous proposons
l'ifac à trois missions la formation aux
métiers de l'animation de la petite
enfance et de l'aide à la personne le
conseil auprès des acteurs locaux et la
gestion de l'animation et d'activités d'
espace socioculturel dans le département
l ifa kevin compte 250 salariés à
guyancourt l'alimentation est à
l'honneur tout au long de l'année c'est
la fête du goût dans la commune les
enfants des écoles et des centres de
loisirs
elles sont invitées à des ateliers et
des activités autour de cette thématique
ce midi à une vingtaine d'entre eux a
été reçue au lycée à d'hôtellerie et de
tourisme de guyancourt camille lambert
vous voulez sentir peut-être
ça sent bon santé
allez-y dites moi vous avez gagné
mademoiselle le romarin sas ans a connu
pour certains beaucoup moins pour
d'autres plantes aromatiques fruits et
légumes n'ont désormais presque plus de
secret pour ces jeunes guyancourt toi
j'ai appris le pomelo ça va pas du tout
ce que c'était en fait c'est un mélange
d'orange de pamplemousse ces exercices
ça permettait de comprendre le milieu
des légumes
ça participe à la découverte du goût
donc c'est compléter un pôle éducation
du goût des enfants ça participe à leur
faire découvrir de nouveaux produits
alimentaires alors montré les fruits de
saison leur expliquer ce qui fait d'une
hygiène alimentaire bien se nourrir pour
passer important un atelier organisé par
la vie au lycée d'hôtellerie et de
tourisme
les enfants de ces centres de loisirs ou
même pu goûter la cuisine des élèves
au menu tomates macédoine et poulet
gratin dauphinois
certes ce que j'adore c'est la
nourriture je connaissais pas du tout
mais en fait c'est un très bon endroit
ils font de la bonne nourriture et
j'adore je pense que ce n'est pas anodin
de les faire venir découvrir les
produits dans un lycée hôtelier de faire
un repas dans un lycée hôtelier ils sont
servis par des élèves qui sont tous très
bien habillés en tenues ils voient des
belles personnes peut-être que chez
certains ça pourrait donner en ça
pourrait déclencher des envies ou des
futures vocations
la fête du goût se poursuit dans la
commune jusqu'à la fin de l'année des
ateliers culinaires seront prochainement
organisées au vélodrome nationale se
délester du poids du passé pour repartir
de l'avant et trouver son bonheur les
clés du passé vous donne la solution
pour positiver
bonsoir noémie de saint sernin bonsoir
basée à montfort l'amaury hauteur et
coach en développement personnel vous
publié chez eyrolles ce livre qui est
donc les clés du passé c'est un ouvrage
pour prouver que la joie est apportée
tous
plus qu'un livre nos amis de saint
sernin c'est aussi une confession vous
avez eu à subir le poids de votre passé
une enfance douloureuse vous avez été
victime de maltraitance se mettre à la
quête du bonheur c'était vital pour vous
ça a été un choix
comme souvent en fait on pense qu'on n'a
pas le choix mais on a toujours le choix
et et à un moment s'est posé cette
question dans ma vie donc en plus des
maltraitances j'ai aussi été ldf à un
moment à 19 ans je me suis retrouvé sans
rien et donc il a fallu faire un choix
le choix de la souffrance le choix du
désespoir ou de regarder un petit peu de
tourner son regard vers la lumière est
de se dire finalement et si c'était
possible et donc c'est le rêve d'une
enfant en fait d'une jeune fille qui un
jour a décidé que son passé
conditionnerait pas sur mon futur et qui
a décidé de croire que peut-être il y
avait d'autres possibles et donc ça ne
s'est pas fait en claquant des doigts
bien évidemment il m'a fallu plusieurs
années de recherche d'observation
beaucoup de lectures énormément et donc
en autodidacte j'ai étudié la
psychologie le la philosophie et même la
spiritualité mais surtout au delà des
livres j'ai vraiment observer et j'ai
vraiment mis en pratique dans ma vie des
choses pour essayer d'en sortir
toute cette expérience vous l'avez
utilisez donc pour venir aussi en aide
aux autres un accompagnement que vous
apportez maintenant depuis une quinzaine
d'années à des couples des parents des
adultes ou encore des enfants pourquoi
c'est important pour vous de transmettre
cette expérience
alors pendant longtemps j'ai café cette
histoire il faut savoir qu'il ya jusqu'à
quelques années il ya trois ans je n'en
avais parlé à personne
voilà j'avais j'avais changé j'avais
réussi à devenir cadre supérieur drh
dans une entreprise voilà j'avais réussi
à lever tous les leviers de la réussite
personnelle et donc cette histoire était
derrière moi et puis un jour je me suis
senti appelé dans cette voie de
transmission et de contributions je rêve
d'un monde meilleur il ya une cause qui
me touche profondément c'est celle des
enfants et de la maltraitance et je suis
convaincu que si tous les parents et si
tout les tous les humains connaissait
ses outils de développement et bien le
nom
s'en porterait mieux une question simple
pourquoi c'est difficile quand on a subi
des traumatismes dans son passé et
d'avancer aujourd'hui de se projeter
aussi vers l'avenir pourquoi c'est
difficile parce qu'on reste collé avec
ce passé en fait on a une mauvaise
lecture et surtout on est conditionné
d'une certaine manière à agir d'une
certaine façon mais c'est simplement
parce qu'on sait pas qui en a une autre
et donc on reste un petit peu accroché
mais ce que je voudrais dire c'est qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire d'avoir une enfance
traumatique non plus pour être sous le
joug du passé on a tous eu des blessures
émotionnelles dans notre enfance que
deux éducateurs et était bienveillant ou
pas ça ça peut venir de tellement de
choses la souffrance des cris des
punitions des manques de valorisation de
confiance
un parent absent un divorce voilà tout
ça va créer des blessures émotionnelles
et donc en fait il n'est pas nécessaire
d'avoir eu un traumatisme comme j'ai pu
le connaître c'est bien évidemment il
est plus difficile de s'en relever
mais ce n'est pas nécessaire et donc en
fait on a tous se passer et comment on
le voit avec des répétitions on attire
les mêmes personnes
on a des difficultés dans les mêmes
domaines dans un cercle vicieux
absolument tourner en boucle
simplement parce que ces blessures il
faut les guérir et donc le passé quand
il revient au présent c'est simplement
pour ouvrir une porte à la guérison et
on est tous capables de s'auto guérir
surtout sans trop dévoiler le contenu du
livre parce que le but c'est aussi de
donner à nos téléspectateurs l'envié de
le lire quelles sont les méthodes et les
petites solutions s'est avancé c'est
possible et qu'on a quand on est bloqué
par son passé on peut avancer
oui oui bien sûr sinon en fait on
possède un pouvoir qu'on ignore alors
bien évidemment ça se fait pas en
claquant des doigts
mais on peut on peut aborder les choses
autrement et d'ailleurs j'ai voulu dans
ce livre déjà mettre une première partie
où je raconte mon histoire pour montrer
que si moi j'y suis arrivé alors c'est
que tout le monde peut véritablement le
faire voilà
et puis ensuite de donner énormément
d'exercice parce qu'un livre hommage en
lui
un élu énormément j'ai lu la
bibliothèque je sais c'est pas suffisant
il faut passer à l'action il faut faire
des choses dans sa vie et c'est pour ça
que j'ai voulu que dans six villes a
énormément d'exercice à m et qui sont
très faciles dans sa vie pour pouvoir
commencer à faire un pas de côté par
rapport à ce passé et à changer
certaines choses et à voir sa vie
changer je le rappelle nos amis de saint
sernin vous publié chez eyrolles se
livrent les clés du passé qu'ils donnent
donc ses clés pour se libérer du poids
du passé merci d'avoir été avec nous
mais ni saint sernin je rappelle vous
êtes basé à montfort l'amaury vous êtes
auteur et coach en développement
personnel et pour plus d'informations
sur votre actualité et aussi sur ce
livre pour retrouver très facilement un
lien d'achat du livre vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site internet
www.noradsanta.org un mot de golf
à présent nous sommes à moins d'un an de
la ryder cup au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et les
capitaines thomass bjorn pour l'europe
et jim furyk pour les états unis ont
continué de faire la promotion de
l'événement auprès auprès du grand
public
après avoir rencontré à lundi les
enfants sur le parcours ils ont
participé hier à une conférence de
presse retransmise dans le monde entier
et parmi les journalistes présents
milliard et demi d'euros
opération séduction tour de la ryder cup
2018 ce mardi 17 octobre lever du soleil
les deux capitaines de la compétition
jim furyk et tomates bio m'ont tapé
quelques balles du haut du premier étage
de la tour eiffel devant les caméras
quelques heures plus tard dans un hôtel
parisien les golfeurs ont lancé
officiellement les hostilités lors d'une
conférence de presse c'est le top départ
du raz du ryder cup 2018 c'est
maintenant les capitaines se rend compte
que c'est du sérieux
ils ont une équipe a formé dans la salle
des dizaines de journalistes venus du
monde entier la conférence a notamment
été retransmise en direct sur les
grandes chaînes de télévision
américaines et britanniques
c'est un événement énorme c'est
l'événement le plus important pour le
golf à l'échelle mondiale sans aucune
question possible c'est un événement qui
passionne les foules en grande bretagne
c'est le 3ème 4ème évènement le plus
important le plus suivi au monde
et là on a l'impression que les français
sont en train de le découvrir tant mieux
il reste encore onze mois pour que la
france se l'approprient sur le plan
sportif pas de grandes annonces pendant
ces trente minutes de questions-réponses
l'américain jim furyk a tout de même
annoncé compter sur la super star tiger
woods si ce dernier avait le feu vert
des médecins
du côté des européens thomass bjorn a
prévenu qu'aucun golfeur n'avait sa
place assurée dans l'équipe y compris
les français il faut pas je pense
qu'elle a été clair espérer ou attendre
à une
comment dire un choix un wild card
naturel pour un français après jean van
de velde et thomas levet victor
dubuisson un quatrième français
sera-t-il sur les greens du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du
28 au 30 septembre 2018 réponse dans
onze mois mercredi c'est bien sûr le
jour des sorties au cinéma et parmi les
nouveautés le dernier film avec le
trappistes omar sy snoeck l'histoire
d'un ex filou devenu médecin s'était
présenté en avant première la semaine
dernière à l'ugc skywest en présence de
la réalisatrice laure et de lévis et
d'omar sy chez mélanie poker c'est une
confidence qu'on ne pensait pas entendre
omar sy et nerveux quand il présente un
nouveau film à saint quentin en yvelines
et pourtant l'accueil est toujours
chaleureux pour le natif de trappes
passage aux devises et passage pur
bonheur de venir à skywest et le cinéma
ou jeu où je venais quand je séchais les
cours
il ya mon lycée qui est juste devant
donc c'est une forme de pèlerinage quoi
c'est lui qu'est ce qui la dote par côme
d'olt il est out
il est beau très beau
je n'avais pas dit a dit quoi et qu'il
était qu'il était quoi quand cette fois
il est neuf
un médecin filous qui arrive dans la
creuse dans les années 50 une libre
adaptation de la pièce du même nom
écrite par jules romains en 1923 un
petit filou qui arrive dans ce petit
village de saint maurice avec un petit
projet un peu magnifique même un peu un
très très banal il vient donc clairement
pour ce faire de l'oseille
mais heureusement il va être sauvée va
être sauvée dans ce film il ya ya ya
on parle aussi de la rédemption la
deuxième chance il des choses qui
peuvent se modifier dans le bon sens
bande l'epim précédent en fait j'ai
adapté le texte à mes personnages
et là j'ai dû adapter mon personnage aux
textes j'ai fait le travail inverse
c'est la première fois que je faisais ça
et c'était très intéressant
l'intérêt pour moi c'était de prendre
cette pièce et de l'emmener ailleurs et
c'est une c'est vraiment une très libre
adaptation on retrouve tout ce qui fait
la saveur le sel de cette pièce les
répliques cultes qui font partie de
notre mémoire collective et de notre
patrimoine littéraire mais pour autant
adapté c'est trahir avec l'aval des
éditions gallimard et de l'ayant droit
de jules romains j'ai vraiment imaginer
un passé un présent et un avenir
j'ai appelé son passé cris
tu as un menteur
reste un menteur
oui tu m'as pas lui qui a subi un petit
métier pour ne pas mourir de faim un
film à la distribution prestigieuse
sabine azéma rufus ou encore christian
hecq n'a que 120 salles ce mercredi 18
octobre
la population de saint maurice est bien
portante les gens bien portants sont des
malades qui s'ignorent monsieur le maire
le nom avant de refermer ce journal un
lancement à skywest après quelques mois
de travaux l'enseigne culturel le furet
du nord a ouvert ses portes au public
aujourd'hui cette arrivée est au coeur
du projet de revitalisation du centre
commercial de montigny le bretonneux
tournée vers les loisirs et la culture
un magasin de 2000 m² qui emploie 45
personnes et une vraie opportunité pour
le groupe de s'implanter à saint quentin
en yvelines propos recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude et mickaël
landreau c'est comme un livre in général
est une très belle zone de chalandise
beaucoup de monde une belle université
beaucoup de bureaux également
donc on sait qu'on aura beaucoup de gens
qui viennent des bureaux et des
communautés qui viennent entre midi et
deux heures donc très beau chiffre le
week end avec une scie démarre à côté
qui draine beaucoup de gens ont vraiment
beaucoup de beaucoup de conditions
étaient étaient rassemblés pour qu'on
puisse se faire
vrai beau magasin ici à saint quentin
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
retrouvé les reportages et le replay sur
notre site internet www.tv 78 points
comme également sur notre application
mobile la tv
78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]